let's see um
i guess there there might be a trumpist
from the bronx holding is am i
understanding that correctly are you a
pro-trump person from the bronx
uh oh uh absolutely not that's just
that's just the name i
chose you're not a trump supporter
oh not at all okay what what's going on
well i just i'm you know being a
democrat it's kind of
hard to date somebody who's baddest
you know or racist and and a hard
far right republican so i was wondering
how do you recommend we do
we deal with with that situation when
you know your
your foreigners families are trumpers
and
are so far right well now let me ask you
your your partner's family or your
partner as well
no no my girlfriend is completely
democrat you know she's
100 percent on my side her dad used to
be a cop he actually got fired for
you know using racist tactics and i am a
fan so it's kind of difficult for me to
interact with him
yeah so i'm wondering what kind of ways
so i'm understanding your girlfriend is
not latino
no she is she's 100 white yeah
that's tough i mean listen uh if if it
were the actual partner
i don't think i could do it you know
it's like if there's a difference over
the degree to which the gender pay gap
exists it's like listen we can bridge
that gap that's no problem
if there's a difference over you know
some nominal religious belief i think
that's fine i think it would be very
difficult to actually date a full-on
trumpist now the family
the family i think is manageable if you
you know think if you're careful and
it's really about how important it is
for you to maintain a relationship with
her family i mean there's people in my
girlfriend's family who are very
conservative
evangelical you know we don't really see
them um just because of distance
but um it's just you know you you
basically are just agreeing not to talk
about politics is
is it now where it becomes difficult is
sometimes there will be people
trumpists who even though everybody
knows it would be better not to talk
about politics
they because it pervades their worldview
they can't help
saying something racist or whatever
and you feel like i can't say nothing
but at the same time if i respond i'm
starting a fight
those situations are really difficult i
don't know how to manage them
right don't agree with you you know
thanksgiving coming up yeah
going to be difficult to be there it's
going to be a mess it's going to be a
mess now i'm
i wonder at multi at families that are
split politically
by thanksgiving are you going to have
the trump people
insisting that joe biden is an
illegitimate president because that's
going to make for some awkward past the
sweet potatoes moments you know
you will you're right well
thank you so much for your advice dude i
really appreciate your show i'm
joining more than ever now thank you so
much i i really appreciate you calling
in
great to uh great pho wow what what
phone calls today
um let's go next to talia
from is it raleigh or rally north
carolina i always forget how it's
pronounced
yes hi hi how are you great it's so
great to be talking to you david
likewise um so i have an interesting
idea that i'd like to run
past you and see what you think sure
so recently you've seen like democrats
like joe manchin who basically act like
republicans and get in the way
of whenever democrats can maybe do
something so i'm thinking we should run
progressives in the republican party i
think our
ideas would be great and it would cancel
out people like joe manchin
and also i think that it's important to
not just play offense but also play
defense
and i mean the republicans do it they
definitely have a republican in the
democratic party and joe manchin
and yeah i was wondering what you think
of that i'd have to think about that so
the idea is instead of
primarying joe manchin with a
progressive in the democratic primary
you run progressives in the republican
primaries
everywhere um i don't think we should
just take over the democratic party we
should probably take over the entire
government because
yeah but i just don't see republican
primaries going to progressives
i think i think it could i think um
republicans
would take too many progressive ideas
like we see in
like florida where they're voting for
minimum wage and um these drug
um drugs running you know the war on
drugs if we run on
issues like that i think we would get a
lot of crossover
if they wouldn't i just i just don't i
can't think of any place where a
progressive would win a republican
primary but let me think about it a
little more okay talia
yeah all right talia from north carolina
very much appreciate the call
that will do it for calls today but fear
not
we will take calls again in the future